you're currently a little high I'm
actually very odd today we're going to
answer a true or false question true or
false bats get it to get funny enough I
did not even notice this was herons just
now out of the 2 million at 8 we want
our arrest whoa right out of the 2.8
million marijuana arrests made between
2001 and 2010 88% were single or simple
possession arise I'm a deficit as true
that sounds like okay that would be true
I just hope they're released now you
know they definitely not continue next
one the main psychoactive substance in
marijuana is triangle 9 tetra drunk and
a bindle oh no they're gonna make fun of
me in the picture hydro Kinnaman all
that's on it right that's true
- studies have found an association
between long-term independent marijuana
use and an increased risk of panic
attacks and panic disorder no mm-hmm
I'm gonna probably say that that is true
people probably get like super paranoid
when they're high just to get triggered
from that like high panic attack gonna
just have a hard I hope not
I'm gonna say that is false
damn I was hoping it was fall as
honestly but this sounds like this
sounds about right
people freak out sometimes cannabinoids
particularly CBD have been shown to make
feelings of nausea and vomiting worse
especially chemotherapy patients oh I
[Music]
think we know CBD makes you feel great
it helps out with my cost exercise a
2015 Bureau of Justice Statistics
analysis indicated that 59% of federal
prison inmates jailed for marijuana
offenses were Hispanic or Latino and
thirteen point nine percent were black
or african-american between the 1994
2012 fiscal years why people aren't
incarcerated at a significantly lower
rate for the same offenses and yes this
is so - true I think this might be true
for every single crime let's do better
change it do better - I suppose that a
New Zealand found that regular use of
cannabis beginning as a teenage Rico
result in the average loss of one to two
IQ points aah-aah-aah
honestly I think that's probably true
because when you're a teenager
our brains are fully developed into what
it needs to be
that make sense but so grateful I guess
woke up a teenager yes well lab studies
have actually proven that smoking weed
makes you want to eat more
I was just thinking about candy yeah I'm
not sure about this one I'm gonna say I
don't think it's true I only said it was
false because I just couldn't see some
doctor sitting in a lab like sick needs
now like see if he's gotta eat the two
most widely recognized subspecies of
cannabis are reefer and giggles did you
imagine walking it to me like hey you
gotta get a smoke as a 2016 marijuana is
a tenth most widely used a recreational
drug in the world in the world I'm gonna
say false okay I'll say false - that
makes sense
cannabis and THC can give you temporary
psychotic sometimes ah I hope I don't
believe that temporary psychotic
symptoms like what the hell do they mean
what do you do oh yo some edibles
edibles I have you oh yeah okay in all
types of ways yes I mean over all the
questions like they're pretty
predictable like I felt like I knew what
a lot of them are it was surprised a few
but I already don't remember a lot of
them yo I was thinking the same I'm my
own we talked about honestly I'm gonna
say no I think overall what we learn we
know how to say THC we know that Delta
nine tetrahydrocannabinol you did that
so well I mean another thing we know is
that we should probably start talking to
some some of our leaders some people in
the political reigns to see if we can
get Meryl
I changed to giggle smoke because that's
what I want to see I wanted I want
action and I want it now
marijuana give us most now
[Music]